Il y a quelques jours, j'ai été invité au mariage de ma cousine
et de sa femme
C'est marrant parce que quand je l'ai dit à mes potes, ils m'ont tous sorti la même phrase
Le week-end prochain, je dois aller à un mariage ...
Oh c'est chiant ça
... homosexuel
Ohh
C'est trop stylé
Alors, je suis obligé de leur répondre
N'importe quoi, c'est juste un mariage normal en 2013, l'union de deux personnes qui s'aiment légalement voilà
J'avoue, c'est trop stylé en vrai
Et avant le mariage je me suis posé une question :
Elles vont porter quoi exactement ?
Une robe ? Un costume ? Enfin, j'en savais rien
Et quand j'ai demandé à ma cousine, elle m'a répondu :
Tu verras au mariage
Et le jour du mariage, elles avaient chacune une robe. Une robe blanche et une noire
Alors quand je les ai vues, je leur ai fait :
Ahhh, le blanc, le noir, le ying, le yang, la complémentarité, l'union. Pas mal
Non, c'est juste que j'aime le blanc, et moi le noir
C'est un peu ying yang quand même
Non, c'est une question de goût
Ok, ok
C'est ying yang
Et en fait le truc que j'attendais le plus pendant ce mariage, c'était quand le maire devait dire:
Je vous déclare mari et femme
Qu'est ce qu'il allait dire du coup?
Je vous déclare femme et femme?
du coup j'attendais que ça, qu'il sorte sa phrase
et au nom de la loi
oh oui
je vous déclare
vas y, dis le
dis le, dis le, dis le, dis le, dis le
unies par les liens du mariage
ah mais non!
on sentait que le maire ça lui changeait un petit peu de son quotidien ce mariage
d'ailleurs à un moment il s'est même fait un kiff avec une petite blague
en tout cas je suis très content de ce mariage
puisque je vais pouvoir faire la bise à 2 mariées
au lieu d'une
Jean Louis Menier a toujours rêvé d'être humoriste
et faire rire la foule des plus grandes salles parisiennes
sous la pression familiale, il reste dans sa commune où il finira maire
parfois il repense à sa vocation perdue ce qui le plonge
dans une profonde dépression
ah oui j'ai oublié un petit détail
ma grand mère a disparu juste avant le mariage
juste avant la cérémonie, disparue
pourtant c'était dans un tout petit village
tout petit, impossible de perdre qui que ce soit
alors qu'est ce qu'on devait faire
est ce qu'on annule le mariage?
pour retrouver la grand mère, ou on fait quand même le mariage
sans la grand mère???
c'est ce qu'on a fait finalement
du coup j'ai passé toute la cérémonie comme ça
ah c'est beau de voir ma cousine si épanouie
peut être que je n'ai plus de grand mère
et on a retrouvé ma grand mère juste après le mariage
elle était en fait dans le mariage d'en face
à l'église... qui était au même moment
je ne sais pas comment elle a pu se tromper de mariage
ça veut quand même dire qu'elle a passé 30 min dans le mauvais mariage
tranquille
ah ma petite fille a choisi un homme finalement
et elle a changé de physique
et toute ma famille a disparu
mais attendez..... ah hum.....
Alzeimer
ensuite il y avait une soirée dans la salle des fêtes où il y avait un peu tout le monde
même le maire, car c'était un tout petit village
et on a du faire un truc que je déteste
écrire un mot dans le livre d'or
et j'ai quand même essayé de la jouer très très très sobre
j'ai quand même fait de la grosse merde
vive les mariées
merde j'ai oublié le "E"
alors cousin tu as écris quoi?
rien
Allez fais voir
j'ai pas terminé
je termine
alors du coup j'ai signé avec une écriture bizarre
pour faire croire que j'écris tout le temps comme ça
t'as vu j'ai une écriture un peu bizarre c'est marrant
à part ça c'était un super mariage
c'était touchant et en même temps on s'est bien amusé
tout le monde était sympa
même le maire
ha je dois y aller je vous laisse-bienne
ah j'avais juste un dernier mot pour vous les internautes
pour vous remercier tout simplement
puisque depuis quelques semaines ma chaine youtube est arrivée en tete du classement
en france, je suis très honoré
d'être le premier Youtuber français
c'est grâce à vous et juste en faisant un petit clic vous avez permis ça
alors pour vous remercier je vais faire encore plein d'autres vidéos
tchao